yo what to do with your boy pillow check
me out on a bootleg Kev podcast
bootleg cab show special guests in here
his new album Stunna it's out right now
yes sir
pillow is here man what's up man how you
feeling he wears his sunglasses at night
and inside during the day you know
start on got weather style don't got
weather I like that [ __ ] yeah you know
that's true man if you ever try to pull
off a hoodie or like a jacket in her
like even though it was hot as [ __ ] yeah
I mean like yeah like I mean like
um I wore like a letterman jacket
um when it was like 104 at Summer Jam
Jesus oh I saw that yeah this was like
recently yeah yeah but you know were you
sweating like a [ __ ] in church yeah
yeah but you can't you can't compromise
the drip cannot compromise never never
compromised you know what pilo said or
not pillow your pillow what [ __ ]
Pepsi said uh
TV ain't got no temperature during the
Big Pimpin video shoot because he had
the um the big Frontline no for sure
that's the TV ain't got no temperature
man yeah that's that's the inspoke you
know what I'm saying he just wanted to
you know Philly Philly sauce down yeah
uh on this album uh Too Short says he
could teach a girl how to make money
with her pee hole
uh yes
oh
yep that'll do it yeah
that's too short man yeah shouts out the
T-shirt I'm not sure that pee holes
technically what makes the money I don't
know the anatomy that wasn't clear yeah
like what is
is it like above or you get that you get
that too short verse back you're like
yes this is right on no this is right
this is what I wanted this is exactly
what I wanted that's exactly what I
wanted I need yeah like I needed him to
talk that greasy ass [ __ ] he did yeah he
said uh he said shake that he said shake
that crack
shake that ass
yeah that that crack
yes he says Shake Your Ass [ __ ] shake
your ass crack yeah not even not even
not even not even the cheese just the
crack no the crack how do you shake the
crack
but I think it's it's like the crack and
then everything is surrounding the crack
that's what you should shake that's fair
attracts are the crack yeah and shout
out to crack Brian Sampson smoked it in
the 80s and he's all right
he's all right he's decent he's all
right
um on this album you have um Is It
Michael Snead yeah Michael Snead he's on
a lot of Records uh at first I thought
it was you just trying to sing yeah I
was like is this like his AKA no no
Michael sneez he's our side of Oakland
super talented
um yeah I think it's up and coming I
think I think he's got an except too you
know I'm saying he's super dope and just
like the chemistry chemistry we have
um
we like every time we would just get in
the studio we'd write some like crazy
some crazy [ __ ] right and um and that's
ended up what happened and like I went
up to the Bay for like two like a week
or two and he was just like pulling up
to the studio and you know
um whether it was like him on a hook or
whether he was like in there vibing like
we would just always come up with
something super dope super unique and um
yeah I think he's super raw he's super
dope yeah I mean he he's got a crazy
voice that's for sure yeah no very
unique very unique you know and that's I
think that's what the bay brings we we
bring something unique every time
you have an album full of slappers my
man thank you thank you a lot of slaps
thank you thank you thank you uh for you
like
do you feel like
where does pillow go from here because I
know what I'm gonna get from pillow when
I press play I'm getting some slaps I'm
getting so [ __ ] feel good some Vibes
some yeah fun good times good times
like I guess
are you is there going to be like a
point in time where you like switch that
[ __ ] up at all
um yeah I think or maybe like Dibble and
Dabble a little yeah yeah I think I
think I mean if you if you really like
look go deep into the album there is
some there is some there is some no no
there's some Vibes on there that are
like really like oh [ __ ] this [ __ ] is
kind of this is some cool [ __ ] like yeah
yeah yeah yeah but like you know like
I like to stay consistent with with with
what you know
what what resonates with me and yeah and
the people who love you and the people
who love me and like and that's really
what I do man I like [ __ ] having a
good time I'm like partying I like
[ __ ] around and just living a good
living a good life but also you know
um life happens throughout throughout
those times and that's where those other
records right kind of come in and do
their thing so it's like whatever is
like
whatever my life is is happening ends up
being on
that's what the music that's the music
I'm gonna make 100
um you have uh the Russell on the album
we talked a bit off the air about the
Russell I just was in Vallejo at his
house which is [ __ ] crazy at a
concert in his house insane now a lot of
people know where he lives yeah
interesting yeah but no but but in a
good way but like it was like really
inspiring to see like just what he's
built and like how he's like really it's
like a really like his dad's there
cooking his mom's there his sister's
helping out like it's like a real family
operation it's like just real dope like
obviously you know he's been doing this
thing for a couple of years but just
talk about the Russell obviously you
know you having him on that record is a
was a big look for him at the time you
know what I mean like it's a huge that
song's fire as [ __ ] again it's crazy
yeah yeah I mean like dude what he's
doing is like
um what I think a lot of people like
like forget what the what it what it's
really about you know what I'm saying
like music
is really supposed to like really like
bring people together yeah and like you
know what I'm saying it's like a
community yeah and like what he's doing
over there is like he's really building
that community and really having people
be a part of it and I think that's
that's what's like a lot of [ __ ] is like
music is just like missing that right
you know and I think he's like really
showing everyone
like what what that means and he's all
doing it himself and like we were just
talking about like man
he if he's got 10 people
rocking with him he's he's gonna like
turn that into a hundred he's gonna turn
100 into a thousand yeah like he's just
he's got it you know what I'm saying
he's gonna he's gonna figure it out and
also like very reminiscent of like Bay
Area Independence independent Roots like
Independence when I think of the bay
when I was growing up I think a
[ __ ] sell it CD's out of the
trunk E40 like yeah like he he's like
that's he he's that in this area yeah
yeah this in this time frame and it's
just it's dope to see it's the dope to
see him continue to grow and and the way
and the way he's just like bro he's like
ripping beats like every day yeah
not even like the bird like he's bro
he's got a schedule in his like office
that's like fine he posts six things a
day and it's like this one's this it's
crazy it's like it's really like
militant how like put together and
organized his operation is man that's
that's that's the real Bay Area that's
that real you know I'm saying organizing
and really really getting it done and
being independent and you know like I
love what he's doing and you know what
I'm saying I commend what he's doing and
I really hope he can reach all the highs
he wants to reach
um talk about uh
obviously Stunna is the I feel like I
mean I think I saw a comparison of like
a Stevie Wonder art and like your your
[ __ ] side by side but the artwork is so
fire because it just reminds me of
something like I would want to buy on
vinyl and hold
yeah like yeah that was that was really
the um
the like the inspo is that was that
Stevie Wonder like we wanted to have
something like reminiscent of like a
vinyl like 70s
funky yeah just remember I was like damn
I want to hold this [ __ ] yeah yeah like
that that's really what was the like the
real
um like inspo behind it we want to do
something like funky vibrant and that's
what and that's what like I think what
the music also like represents it's like
it's it's the music is vibrant it's
colorful and
um it's just like that it it sounds like
it sounds like it sounds like the cover
looks yeah it's and and the title feels
like an album called stunner yeah you
know what I'm saying you know I try to
put it all together trying to think one
plus one equal two 100 man no it's great
great great artwork
um orange vinyls maybe I want yeah come
on all right holla at the powers that be
they're gonna be vinyls coming yeah yeah
oh limited edition no 50 pieces yeah
yeah come on limited edition that's not
that that's what that's in route you
know what I loved about you uh the last
time you came you brought uh you brought
me a hat right but you brought me um
like the ones you just give away you
didn't bring me the new era and you were
like yo next time I see you I'm gonna
bring you the new era one and I was like
that'd be sweet because I my big head
can't fit in this and I've seen you
seven times since then so yeah um
oh yeah I wear seven and a half look me
and you both got Noggins yeah and we we
we're ahead of our class we are Bone
Thugs-N-Harmony
you know
did you ever get made photo for having a
[ __ ] domes that's dumb thugs in
harmony ahead of my class [ __ ] you
know I got I got a lot on my brain from
my head yeah like a [ __ ] I don't know
man you got you got that I got like you
got that [ __ ] something's going on up
there yeah I think my parents [ __ ] me
up when I was a kid or something yeah
like like my head never reformed after I
was born you know like yeah yeah you you
definitely gotta appear like newborn
baby head
[Laughter]
I still got my soft spot up here it's
like a little salt that's why I always
wear a hat bro no no I mean like you
know you always wear a hat too but you
know I'm you know I'm good
I'm cool my head's just really you gotta
[ __ ] you got something going on there
yeah I got it I thought y'all got a
noggin you know I definitely had my
class you know but yeah so what's up
with my [ __ ] hats
just like you have me on the Morton's
dinner from three years ago when we when
we
hmm
I guess people from the bay don't pay
their bets oh God no bro every time I'm
like bro let's go be like oh next week
I'm like all right okay
for that stupid ass shirt oh man you
know I actually like that Warriors team
that's that's a Warriors team I can
appreciate do we believe so I can
appreciate that team it's this new team
I got problems why you got the problems
with us it's really more with the KD era
of the situation okay but what about
this year this year I can't hate on I
like I like kaminga I like I like uh
Moody I like what happened with the Suns
though don't worry about it what
happened with those guys I actually kind
of know hmm
okay so
Let's Build It Business this is the
bootleg podcast
so from what I heard from reliable
sources about as reliable as they can
get hmm
Chris Paul lost the locker room man in
the last like two games
and he wasn't talking to his teammates
um after the first half of game six I
guess he like shut down wasn't talking
to nobody and like everybody kind of
like nobody was yeah that's what I heard
and like everyone was like looking for
him for like leadership well at the end
of the day was like that's your court
general and like he's being like a
spoiled little like because someone had
told him
going into halftime on game six like hey
they're targeting you because they were
targeting him on defense like yo like
sit down we got that's why we got you
know Aaron holiday whatever
he just shut down and didn't talk to
nobody and then game seven happened and
we got [ __ ] knocked yeah no that was
crazy I was hoping we I honestly was
hoping I was hoping we were gonna get
rid of Chris Paul to be honest but he's
oh he's still there oh yeah yeah I mean
listen one of the greatest of all time
but
I don't know dude Devin Booker's on the
cover of 2K that's my Championship God
damn it yeah no that's that's nice I
know and I was thinking to myself I was
thinking to myself as like why is he on
the cover when when's when who wants to
be on the cover this year Steph Curry
bro he's been on the cover multiple
times what do you mean
how many times but they're trying to put
new guys on the cover it's not like
they're gonna put jokic on the cover
nobody's gonna buy [ __ ] someone a
video game with him a seven foot me on
the [ __ ] cover No One's Gonna buy it
that's why he doesn't even have a
[ __ ] sneaker deal two-time MVP no
shoe deal look at how he looks looks
like a [ __ ] Z looks like me both I I
I could bet he like he he's like he
looks like he smells like a crazy like a
Subway sandwich you think he's out here
[ __ ] though he got to be bro you
think so he gotta be bro he's the he's
The Gutter and you're thinking like in
his home country oh no he's running he's
like pulling like tractors and running
[ __ ] do you think the women look like
him in his home country no they're
probably wet tight they're probably out
there you know what is it from Serbia
maybe yeah Serbia have you been over
there no where's the wildest like uh
country you've been to because of your
music obviously
um
probably like Japan Japan was pretty
cool Japan was pretty interesting I've
heard about some uh establishments over
there nice hmm yeah Japan's Japan gets
pretty it gets pretty loose out there
you like yeah like like people get so
drunk bro they're not too loose not too
loose people just people are people get
so drunk and they just like sleep in the
street and nobody touches them no but
it's kind of like where you're from yeah
except for yeah no sleep in the street
anyway you know like bro literally like
I'm in San Francisco by the way you're
from you're not from San Francisco but
no but like literally people be like
full business suits bro just [ __ ] up
on the street on the street just like
ripped and nobody touches them they
they're able to like wake up and just be
like all right bro it's insane they're
like you'll see like just piles of
people just like sleep so Strangers Like
bro it's crazy bro it's insane I need to
go to Japan bro it gets so loose out
there and then like like 6 a.m you can
just go hit a little Ramen spot I just
wanna I wanna rent I want to rent the uh
Mario Kart little rentals you could
drive around Tokyo yeah no those you
have to get a um somebody did it
someone's like you got to get a license
there's like a certain license you got
to get like at like at like right when
you get there because I want to go to
like the uh bootleg area of Japan you
know I've heard they got like high level
fake shoes over there like high level
like you couldn't be able to tell type
[ __ ] you know no I mean do you know if
that's how you get down you know I mean
I'm saying that's how I get down I'm
saying I wouldn't mind checking it it's
just my checking it up my name is boot
like Kev I used to you are I used to get
packages caught up in customs in high
school when I was [ __ ] selling fake
[ __ ] to people on eBay yes that is that
how you got your name yes
wow yeah a lot of a lot of uh burnt CDs
mixtapes a lot of uh fake shoes fake
purses
pirated movies
all kind of movies
not those ones actually I used to sell
passwords though I'd get like the
browsers pass so oh man that's that's
that sounds like a win yeah you know
sometimes sometimes you might hit a
bread well I I don't know if I read it
but I know reddit's where you get all
the only fans right but uh oh this guy
I've heard yeah no that's what I've
heard hey what happens bootleg cab we
gotta stop the interview to tell you
what our good friends at my bookie
football season has started my favorite
time of the year because I love to
gamble on football it makes watching
football so much fun it's my like
literally I just love watching football
and I love it even more when I got money
on the line and no matter where you are
right now what state what country you
can get in on the action it's a winning
season go to my bookie sign up for a new
account register and get that double
deposit bonus using the promo code
bootleg now let me tell you what that
means that means when you go to my
bookie let's say you make a 250 deposit
using the promo code bootleg you'll have
five hundred dollars to gamble with
that's right they're gonna double your
[ __ ] money right now they got the
prop builder you could bet on uh whether
or not I don't know well Matthew
Stafford throw for three touchdowns will
Kyler Murray rush for a touchdown you
could put all those on one thing and
secure the [ __ ] bag all right
get online with your boy let's get this
money together my bookie go sign up with
that promo code bootleg and double your
deposit right now go register do you go
on Reddit for the prom
um
[Music]
when it's time to when it's time to you
uninstall Reddit from your phone because
if you because it's [ __ ] up if like
someone accidentally like you know I
mean yeah I just try not to let people
go through my phone that's fair you know
what I'm saying I'm I'm pretty pretty
pretty pretty particular about your
phone yeah you know you might you know
you don't you know what you could find
so if you're in a relationship with a
girl is she allowed to have your
password
um
I no I don't believe that I don't
believe in that I really don't like I
feel like because like if you don't
trust me why are we even doing this why
are we doing this and like yeah like we
we should be able to like some so
everyone deserves privacy yeah every
everyone's deserves something that's
theirs yeah 100 I agree man yeah like
yeah like
I know like yeah like if if we don't
trust each other with them what are we
doing what are we doing here I just had
my girl uh recently she uh
somehow I ended up on she didn't have a
Twitter account so my Twitter's been
[ __ ] up for a while I mean since the
Inception I just follow all the porn
[ __ ] it's terrible and then to do a
little she just scored went through she
randomly was like yo one thing you're
like no no no no I'm not that stupid I
ain't liking nothing crazy because you
know everyone can see what you like on
Twitter
she's like why is everybody on Twitter
that you follow a porn star and I was
like
I don't know babe I've had that Twitter
for a long time and [ __ ] I barely am on
there yeah no no man I mean you don't
need to you just gotta go on Twitter
Twitter's wild no you could just go on
Twitter and just put whatever you want
is on there yeah you could just you you
know you could Buzz down damn there
anywhere have you supported any young
ladies by uh subscribing to the ofs uh
that's not really my that's not really
my swag you just get it on Reddit for
free
uh I mean you know who knows I don't
know
I don't know I'm not I'm not into uh
self-incrimination but hey so
San Francisco's crazy Place uh I had a
friend who was just out there we've
talked about the bippin thing before on
the show
do you feel like it's getting better at
all like recently with like because last
time I was there the CVS's downtown were
closed the Walgreens were closed because
of the people just running and stealing
[ __ ] like you feel like it's starting to
turn a tide at all
um I just think that everyone's getting
my might be getting a little bit smarter
obviously you still get those like
tourists and [ __ ] that come in and they
don't really know
um and also there's just probably they
just took everything already yeah
ain't none left yeah there's no the
bippers there's only so much [ __ ]
there's so much [ __ ] you could take yeah
and something like yeah like we were
talking about some people sometimes
people just leaving their their windows
roll down yeah like when we were I was
like guys if we go anywhere we're
leaving every Window World down just
roll the window down because like you
know what I'm saying let people look
through yeah don't keep nothing in there
don't keep nothing in there is that what
you do
um I I try not to drive when I'm I
usually just Uber everywhere that's fair
you just just um you know I'm not you
know I'm not tied to anything yeah
that's smart that's smart or or just
just don't leave anything in the car you
just had a dope event uh Thursday night
Chase Center well [ __ ] it's not the
Oracle it's not the Oracle anymore they
moved they moved they moved they moved
how cool was that man it was incredible
bro
um that was the the first time that's
ever happened like you know I I don't
know like I got to throw my album
release party
center right where the Warriors play big
deal for you you're a real Warriors fan
I like most of these people yeah and it
was like um it was it was dope for just
all the whole Community come out we had
we did I did some collabs with some
Brands yeah and then we had our
emergency it looks super dope man you
know it was it was an amazing event it
was all ages so a lot of people were
able to bring their kids and and it was
just a dope event there was like food
trucks and it was just dope man it was
just dope to be able to bring the bay
out for for the release and and be able
to celebrate the release one one
critique I have I don't know why you
hired Nico Blitz to DJ oh man oh man I
like Nico man why
I like him man he's a good kid he's a
good kid wait he's he's 30. well you
know he did he did that he's good he's a
good kid though
Nico produces my radio show I know he's
a good kid I'm just [ __ ] with you no
but he no he did the he did the dollar
hits in L.A he didn't do the chase
Center oh okay so I'm doing something oh
no but yeah no but Nico's a great guy
yeah no but the question is but that
event was you're his hero no man man
he's my hero man oh you're his hero he's
my hero at a certain point in time he
may have had like a light pillow Shrine
in his apartment I don't think it's
there anymore but there may or may not
have been a lot of pillow stuff together
in one area in the corner of a room with
candles man I I I would hope someone
someone's prayer I would hope someone's
praying for me man I would hope
I would hope have you had like any crazy
ass experiences like that where like
maybe you like there's like a fan who's
just like super obsessed or like pops up
somewhere where you're like what the
[ __ ] like maybe like a fan crosses the
line I guess that you're comfortable
with
um
man dude there was
um there was this one time somebody like
um
I wouldn't even call it that
but like this person was like showing up
to a lot of places that I was like at
and you know and there was one time like
and obviously like it was that was in
the bay okay but then then there was
this one time I was uh I was doing yoga
and I was in in like Culver City
and that person showed up
whoa and I'm like you know Clover City
is like a little very far from the base
it's far from the bay six and a half
hours away or so it's six hours away but
showed up at the yoga spot yeah wow it
was pretty interesting so did they I
don't know if I was there for you no no
no it might have just been a coincidence
though I don't know that's pretty not I
mean that's random as [ __ ]
okay
so yeah what happened did they like come
up to you yeah yeah no I mean like they
said what's up but like I think it was
it might have just could have been a
coincidence right and I'm just being a a
[ __ ] douche a [ __ ] yeah I'm being
a douche and you know what I'm saying I
would never want to wish that on anybody
yeah but
um so yoga does that like I've never
done it I heard it's good for you though
no it's man I've been I I've been doing
High yoga for like almost a year now you
love it I love it it's a it's like it's
really a life hack it is very very very
uh very you know Zend you know Mind Body
Spirit you feel like healthier doing it
yeah you know because you know all that
[ __ ] like helps like your insides and
[ __ ] and you know like you know in my in
my profession like you know we drink a
lot of alcohol and of course do a lot of
crazy [ __ ] yeah but like all that stuff
like
um like activate certain things you're
stretching and you're moving certain
things and you're you're you're like the
insides like really get that flow of
like how they're supposed to be like
stretched out and like moved around and
the blood is like transferring from your
head to right powering your feet and all
that stuff is like really and it's like
also like an exercise like they're like
really burning calories and [ __ ] bro
I'll be in there like literally like
sweating bro like
like sweating does it get funky in those
things that look there's there's like
the like the bigger corporate spots like
where they're they're just like muelling
those spots are a little funky yeah you
gotta find you gotta find the little
like little Tucky like Mom and Pops
joints that are like independently or
just like kind of like smaller so it's
like you you don't get that like kind of
like cow mule kind of thing it's like
they're just like loading 30 people in a
room and then the next 30 people come
they're not cleaning it but usually like
the spots that I go to is just like they
go in there wipe like they make sure
everything wipe down they wipe down all
the weights and would you consider
yourself like a spiritual guy
uh yeah I would I would like to think so
I would like to think so religious
um you [ __ ] with I mean you know we've
had our bouts with Jesus Christ you know
yeah I I think I think you remember that
interview we did we were like Jesus
Christ Jesus yeah I mean I I was so
funny at some point yeah like I think uh
I know I yeah I would say a little bit
religious but like I know I'm more like
but I would more say more spiritual like
I feel like someone's up there running
this whole thing right I feel like I
feel like most people probably feel that
way right where you're probably like I'm
not sure I'm gonna commit to any of
these man-made religions as much as like
trying to get right like with you know
yeah I yeah I don't think uh
uh I don't think God looks like the uh
the guy that they're like
putting out there so not like Morgan
Freeman
I mean he might look like Morgan Freeman
I'd be cool that would be actually cool
yeah I'll I'll I wouldn't be mad if God
look like Morgan Freeman and he had his
voice
the voice would really say the voice
would set it off yeah that sets it off
appreciate y'all watching but listen our
partners at Blue chew they got you
handled fellas and Etc whatever you are
they got it if you got a dick blue shoe
is for you because they will make sure
your dick performs at all time levels I
mean like look Braun his first three
seasons with the heat type levels I mean
your wife will thank you for it
everybody will thank you for it [ __ ]
even if you just take a blue chew and
jerk your dick it's a it's a stronger
jerk I swear to God stronger [ __ ] jerk
for sure you're gonna be beating your
dick like a stole something
so what you got to do is go to
bluetooth.com right now use the promo
code bootleg right now and you're gonna
get your first month free and this is
the great thing about Bluetooth the same
active ingredients as Viagra and scialis
but uh you don't got to go to the
doctor's office yeah who wants to go
hang out at the doctor's office and be
like hey Doc you got some [ __ ] pills for
me nobody wants to do that no you sign
up at Blue use the promo code bootleg
and you're getting your first month
delivered to your door in discreet
packaging I'm telling you you're gonna
thank me later all right if you've
gotten Bluetooth already just DM me tell
me just just DM me no photos just tell
me how you know let me just tell you
it's [ __ ] amazing our producer
Cyrus's daddy 70 took the Bluetooth he's
[ __ ] just beating down all the senior
citizen [ __ ] available in Arizona right
now so go to bluetooth.com use that
promo code bootleg or just hit the link
in the description of this video let's
get back to the interview remember have
you ever done mushrooms yeah I do [ __ ]
with mushrooms but I go a lot I've never
really actually like really really gone
in I haven't done the actual
um like the actual like shrooms but
you've done like gummies or chocolate
like chocolate yeah and I [ __ ] with that
too I like that a lot have you like done
a lot where you like really have like a
[ __ ] no like a breakthrough I I I
haven't got I haven't got that deep
enough are you just usually just like
you know it's about it's it's yo
honestly if you like take like a micro
dose if you're out if you're like just
want to party it's way better than
drinking or getting high I feel like
yeah you know what you know what it
feels like bro
if you take a couple little pieces yeah
it kind of feels like the good part of
the pill
see I've never done a pill in my life so
I'm glad to know that yeah like like my
like Molly and [ __ ] like if you've done
like the the good part and it doesn't
have like the like the bad part the bad
part it really just feels like that real
like happy yeah like loose loose kind of
what kind of kind of feel so yeah I kind
of [ __ ] with that like if I'm in like
if I'm in Vegas or something I'll kind
of like take a couple chocolates have
some drinks you know what I'm saying
catch a little Vibe and then I feel
great shout out to the Molly man
I think a Molly I just think of Mac Dre
R.I.P all right Peter drizzle never
really was a big fan I'm not gonna lie
for real not like I'm not it's not that
I'm not a fan I just never was like yeah
yeah this is super super I'm not like
I just never was really into this [ __ ]
yeah I didn't grow up in the bay yeah
yeah I mean yeah I mean he he was
definitely um I'm not not a fan but I'm
also not like a fan yeah I got you guys
you know like Pastor Troy not not a fan
but yeah not a fan yeah no [ __ ] will
wants to shoot me right now damn hey no
passive choice no no no I love Pastor
Troy I love we read but like I'm like
that's them right that's it right yeah
he had the [ __ ] WWE belt he had that
WCW world championship belt with that
Falcons jersey huh and I love some Mac
Dre songs I just never like dived into
his catalog you know what I mean he's
got some he's got real catalog so what I
heard is like before him passing he was
kind of like um more hip like like
people were [ __ ] with him in like
Berkeley and more like real looking guys
were like really into him and then once
he passed away like everybody started to
embrace him would that be accurate will
would you say because you were there
yeah I would say that yeah
which is unfortunate because I feel like
a lot of times that takes people like
passing away to like really be fully
appreciated you know yeah and I think
that's a uh that's something that's like
overall it's like man you're just in
this life you never just gonna get the
credit that you deserve I mean he he's
influential as [ __ ] man yeah and like I
mean like the the truth the trill TV was
like that was like literally the
backdrop of what the hyphy movement was
like that was like the real like like
the like the bones the [ __ ] dollars
framework yeah that was the square one
yeah like that was like the scriptures
he he put a real like backdrop to what
the music and what people were talking
about at that time and that's what I
feel like
also elevated his like Legend status you
know what I'm saying he really gave the
backdrop some of the best uh artwork of
all time his [ __ ] album artwork was
crazy I remember going into like virgin
and seeing it I'm like yo this [ __ ] is
wild this guy's
[ __ ] the genie of the lamp Yeah final
Dragon like come on man that's legendary
yeah who uh okay so I want to give you
flowers here because
I think if we're looking at the bay area
right there's 40 and Too Short
those are like okay 42 short then
there's Mac Dre
then I'd say there's like G-Eazy
but I feel like after a guy like G I
mean obviously there's like to keep the
sneaks and the jackers of the world and
and uh hot shout out to Hiro uh I know
Hyrule day just happened but I kind of
feel like consistency you're kind of
like knocking on [ __ ] what eight nine
years straight you've really been like
representing the city at a super high
level I feel like you're really kind of
starting to like catapult yourself in
like the conversation of being like all
time
[ __ ] from the city man man oh I mean
that's an honor from the area right yeah
from the area I mean that's an honor you
know I mean like I think that was you
know when I want to set out
um uh the journey because I knew it was
going to be a journey and it's still the
journey and that's just from my
perspective because I know like big Von
and uh Dame will watch this and have a
[ __ ] absolute [ __ ] convulsion but
just from from someone who's not from
the bay yeah you know yeah
of course yeah it is Legends they put
together their top Bay Area listen I'm
just like what the [ __ ] but again I'm
not from there so yeah yeah no I mean
dude like just just just the base is
such a legendary spot for like rap and
music and the in culture culture in
general and just to be just for me to be
able like like
for you to be like a in that
conversation you know what I'm saying
because you you might not even be 100
right or one and day might not be 100
right but just to be in that
conversation with those with those names
the people that are like oh like I grew
up too and people that I like look up to
um man that's
that's love man because I think of it
like this I'm like okay probably the
most important movement out of the bay
the last 10 years is 100 hpk gang and
you've 100 I mean shout out to keilani
in terms of hip-hop you've been the most
relevant and successful person in HBK
gang to come from it rather and to me
like HBK gang is like a moment in time
yeah that like was like crazy like when
you guys would do those yearly concerts
and all that [ __ ] but the fact that like
you were able to like take that and
never stop and just keep going up up you
know what I mean I mean I mean I I think
that just goes back to like I mean
during those days man we were out we
were around a lot of great people like I
mean Sue is like like yeah
like like I'm nowhere where I'm at
without soup
cool John like you know what I'm saying
that movie almost [ __ ] crazy that was
that's I but that's I think that's that
album really like
I feel like that's when things change
for you okay yeah no one to one thousand
percent like um because I remember you
had was it art was it RB what's the one
where you had the baby with a little uh
more [ __ ] more gold chains yeah that
was the uh
what was the song in there I used to
play in the club going to work yeah
going on to work yeah it was hard but I
feel like at that time you were kind of
like the little homie yeah like you were
like yeah we love his Beats like he also
raps a little like yeah no for 1000
um but yeah like I mean without those
guys like uh like
I'm nowhere in that conversation for
sure you know what I'm saying those
those people helped me so much and those
people helped guide me those people gave
me the confidence to even do what I'm
doing you know what I'm saying Sage Sue
cool John all those guys like those are
the people that are like I I continue to
look up to you know what I'm saying just
and as humans and in life so it's like
um just to be in that is like yeah
HBK is like incredible yeah fire uh who
would you put in your like uh your Bay
Area rapper Mount Rushmore
um whoo that stuff
um
I feel like three slots are already
taken so the fourth One's Gonna Be the
controversy but God damn save for
yourself I mean if you really if you
really think about it bro
like impact and all this [ __ ] bro
I really like you can really make an
argument for I am too bro up there for
fair like you know what I'm saying for
what Spawn from him okay so we're
putting imsu up there
Mac Mac Dre short 40. those are the four
I like it
I mean like I I know you know that's
that that's me that's what I'm saying
like no I mean I don't feel like people
give Sue enough credit oh a thousand
percent bro I mean like bro like how
like
like how great are you if if if you the
only one that's great
um you know what I'm saying like how
many people don't spawned off from the
imsu tree from from the tree yeah you
know what I'm saying and like I don't
think
a lot of people Overlook it because
we're still like that it's like still
like happening you know I'm saying 100
it's still happening right now yeah
people are still like living in that
like you know people still do you guys
still talk often you and two yeah I mean
we talk here and there like you know
like you know he's like we we both had a
busy you know what I'm saying got a lot
of [ __ ] going on but yeah I just talked
to him not so long ago
great guy awesome great awesome guy bro
yeah just still a great friend of mine
still my brother to this day yeah how's
uh how's John doing yeah John I brought
out John at the chase Center you know
what I'm saying he's awesome you know
what I'm saying like he he had you know
he had had a situation not like a couple
years ago or like right when the
pandemic happened but he's cool he's
he's smooth he's you know back moving
around he's he's gravy you know what I'm
saying uh deal there's a lot of dope
energy
out of the area right now because you
look at we talked about the Russell
yourself a guy like Simba who's been
around for a long time no for sure Larry
Larry Larry Jesus like bro like
literally like bro like he might be up I
mean you know what he's in that
conversation I totally I totally skipped
over that for sure and and because he's
up there bro like literally consistently
December Larry like these are people
that I've like been seeing since like
2006 2007 bro like we were back in high
school trying to do this [ __ ] yeah Simba
was like dude I used to be just running
around with amen all over the bay like
he's a managed Artistry and then Larry
June I know about Larry June forever bro
like yeah
like he had uh what was what's he had a
[ __ ] shoe collab four or five years
ago with that what's that skate company
he had to shoot with uh what's up well
look look yeah that one but yeah not
June's you know he's yeah like he he's
for sure like I mean he's
damn he's the guy yeah he's the guy he's
the guy I totally feel terrible because
I didn't mention him earlier but yeah no
no he he he's up there bro he's and he's
also like really that like the real bear
let that independent you know what I'm
saying he's really pushing that line you
know and like not a lot of people have
been able to do it he's he's doing he's
doing and probably going to continue to
do it because like three four albums a
year like Jesus Christ you know what I
mean yeah he's working man he's working
for sure we got to stop the interview
tell you about our partners at Odd Socks
well first of all let's check out the
brand new collab
look at these the bootleg capsock you
see my pink ass face on those [ __ ]
socks nobody wants to buy those we're
going to figure out a way to give them
away though uh but look Odd Socks the
most comfortable socks in the world
um and the best thing about Odd Socks is
they're our family man I've been walking
with these guys for about 10 years now
and I will not wear anything else on my
feet like I swear to God I'm about to
take my shoe off I'm about to take the
look what is this
smells great too that's an odd sock
right there that's an odd sock basic you
know what I'm saying we [ __ ] with Odd
Socks you should too they got the crazy
licenses we're talking about Nickelodeon
shout out to Patrick [ __ ]
Cheez-Its Baywatch
how about macaroni underwear look at
these boys right here let's just crack
these [ __ ] open real quick what
do we got in here
come on man
yeah a little Pop-Tart underwear you
know what I mean yeah these are the Odd
Socks Basics all right so if you go to
the website right now order you some
underwear order you some socks use the
promo code bootleg Kev that's one word
all together bootleg Kev and you will
save 20 off at checkout go to
oddsocksofficial.com one more time
that's oddsocksofficial.com promo code
bootleg Kev and you will save 20 off
your order of course we're presented by
Odd Socks and we are proud to say so all
right let's get back to the interview
what about like I feel like you're
you're average like once every year and
a half you're dropping or so yeah
do you feel like because I just I do you
know I saw I don't know if you saw this
you probably did you see DJ head
challenge a bunch of La rappers to get
on a pillow beat
I feel like you've kind of stepped away
a bit in terms of like your profile as
like a producer
yeah I mean for other
pink like I I'm like
I'm spending a lot of time like well one
producing for myself because like I'm
starting [ __ ] from zero because your
whole album is you right well for the
most part like well a lot of well there
is a lot of co-production and okay so I
went to a live with different producers
but well we're really starting [ __ ] from
zero to to where it's at to 100 you know
what I'm saying so like that [ __ ] takes
time and then also I'm trying to like
every time I'm trying to do something
I'm trying to level up and I'm trying to
like evolve the sound so it's like
there's it takes time to do that and
[ __ ] like that but like I think
I definitely want to like definitely hop
in that bag you know what I'm saying I
definitely can't hop in that bag I think
just sometimes people forget that I
produce
in general you got a great tag man yeah
I think people think people just think
that's like like my son like oh it's
like a pillow song nah but like I made
the beat I made the beat yeah but yeah I
think just a lot of people just forget
that I produce so it's like and also
like like
not just like oh here's a beat like
producing you got to give a little
Russell a Beat we got some we got some
we got stuff but like like we we've been
we talked about doing some doing some
things but I know he he just he got he's
he's here come to Vallejo man that I
think that's just something I just gotta
come to the V I'm gonna just I'm gonna
go stay at the Hampton Inn yeah I stayed
there I'm gonna go stay at the Hampton
Inn like right right by the Six Flags
yeah shout out to the crest yeah shout
out to the crest man there's a wild wild
homeless [ __ ] situation going on by
that 7-Eleven between the king's
Marketplace or the 7-Eleven [ __ ]
had he was walking a goddamn wolf and he
had a stick and he kept beating the dog
and I was like
damn the thing the things you see in the
bay
they just uh decriminalized troops well
it was in San Francisco or San Francisco
because I think it was already
decriminalized in Oakland yeah yeah that
was the first place to do it right yeah
yeah I know in Portland everything's
decriminalized so
I'm over it okay
yeah you I feel like the whole are you
pretty popping in like Portland Seattle
I feel like that's kind of like extended
Bay yeah like all that all that's like
them is like our cousins yeah you know
so like we shall we they show us a lot
of love we we love we love love them up
there and I feel like you know a lot a
lot of the lifestyles are the same too
it's like we smoke a lot of weed hmm get
[ __ ] up
have a good time they like doing that
well listen man the album is out Stunna
stun is out fire project thank you lots
of good vibes great Vibes just throw
that [ __ ] on and just have fun yeah
yeah throw that [ __ ] don't have have
fun smoke a little weed drink I like the
outro the freestyle the uh what's it
called the um my ghetto Republican
that's just hard thank you man yeah and
you had E40 do the intro yeah what oh
yeah that was pretty cool like that all
happened within like a couple days
before yeah E40 on the intro yeah
kicking the whole joint off again man
houses houses lumpia is it good um yeah
no it's fired they have like a bunch of
[ __ ] I had the like the cheeseburger
Olympia was pretty far
E40 has a cheeseburger what look at that
speaking of Nico Blitz take that
[ __ ] off
the [ __ ] lunch table his [ __ ] logo
just pops up on the TV come on it's like
the Philippines it's like the Filipino
[ __ ] that's the universe witchcraft
going on what we were talking about
earlier bro this is the universe bro the
universe
shout out to Nico Blitz uh nah but yeah
nah uh the project is open shout out to
E40 I'm curious because I love lumpia
and I know he's got like the lumpia
company yeah no he's got his Turf
burritos the turf burrito he's got his
ice cream goon with a spoon
the tequila solid yeah no I've never had
the wine because I don't drink wine oh
the the wine the wine gets loose it gets
you loose
do they still have a 40 water does this
still happening I I don't know I don't
know if I don't know if that if that's
the thing uh uh anymore what product are
you dropping if you could drop a product
um
damn
that's that's tough
Royal honey oh the honey pack yeah yeah
angle I've never used a honeypack you're
a liar no I promise in your life you've
never taken a rhino or a honey pack no
my mind one time I should get up of
course it does but have you ever been
super shit-faced and been like [ __ ] Nah
if I'm if I if that happens I'm the I'm
just pure gummy worm I'm done there's
wait a second it's a wrap I'm not even
for the tribe you've never even taken a
Mexican Viagra no bro
because the thing is if if I if I'm if
I'm too ripped like that
there's no way I should be [ __ ]
if my [ __ ] if I look my [ __ ] you think
Barry Bonds needed steroids to hit 73
home runs yes could he have hit 50
without him sure don't you want to have
a 73 home run season no you know
you know but see you you can't just do
that like you don't want to like you
want to crutch on that you know no of
course not but when I first started
dating my wife I was like okay
you just you want to just wake it up I
gotta wake that thing up
[Music]
so I'm going gorilla when me and my wife
first started dating and I started I was
like every time I was off of a half a
[ __ ] Mexican Viagra you were just
waking waking that thing up I was like
man we go we gonna bring her in we're
never gonna let her go yeah he was going
gorilla the whole time the Rhino pills
though they get to get you in the
sinuses like right here the Honey's a
little different I heard the Honey's got
off I'm sure it's all got off awful for
you but so honey
coming soon even though he doesn't use
it yeah you know I mean you know I don't
know there it is man I appreciate you
going up the new album stream that thing
go buy a hat that he won't uh give me uh
because he's a liar and um yeah and um
maybe uh maybe I'll see you in San
Francisco man maybe maybe there it is
the Taylor Street